[Music]
with the latest halo infinite gameplay
reveal it's the perfect time to look at
the evolution of halo's gameplay
and how it has gradually evolved across
all the mainline games
very few franchises have maintained the
legacy that halo commands in the gaming
world
the impact of halo and master chief as
cultural icons remains undisputed for
many fans
and became one of the driving forces in
establishing microsoft and the xbox in
the console gaming space
[Music]
it all began with halo combat evolved
released in 2001 as a launch title for
the xbox the first halo introduced
players to master chief the iconic super
soldier
and featured responsive and satisfying
gunplay making it one of the standout
console shooters
as master chief you had an energy shield
and a health bar keeping you alive as
you fight the two main enemy factions
the covenant and the flood there were
plenty of weapons but unlike other
popular shooters that allowed you to
carry
multiple weapons halo restricted you to
carrying only two at a time
this forced the player to experiment
with different loadouts to deal with a
variety of enemy types using both unsc
and covenant weapons vehicular combat
put the player into a third person
perspective as they controlled tanks
ghosts banshees and the classic warthog
the game's ai would even ride along on
the warthog and provide suppressing fire
from different parts of the vehicle
that eventually became an essential part
to the campaign's gameplay
halo also had multiplayer support but
this came before xbox live was even a
thing
meaning split screen co-op for the
game's campaign and competitive
multiplayer were the main ways friends
would dive into the game together
halo quickly became a commercial and
critical success and staked its claim as
one of the best shooters of all time
and thankfully halo's success paved the
way for its sequels
sir permission to leave the station for
what purpose master
chief to give the covenant back their
bomb
halo 2's biggest change from the get-go
was duel building there was something
extremely novel and honestly badass
about mixing together old and new
weapons
for some entertaining combinations there
was also the addition of a whole new
character to the campaign
the arbiter the arbiter could cloak
himself and remain camouflaged for short
periods of time
but didn't have the flashlight that
master chief's spartan armor suit had to
illuminate dark areas
the health bar from the first game was
no longer a part of the gameplay
instead the player would need to just
worry about the energy shield
new enemies also made their debut in
halo 2 with the brutes
a hostile group that would go on to
fight both the unsc
and the elites
the most significant evolution from
combat of all to halo 2 was the
inclusion of xbox live support
making halo 2 the first game in the
franchise to officially offer online
multiplayer players would simply
select a game mode and then be
automatically connected with other
gamers online
based on the mode and map type bringing
the massive 16 player matches to the
mainstream
rather than just the small subset of
players who had the means to set up lan
parties
halo 2 would also mark the beginning of
a lengthy absence from pc ports for
future titles in the franchise
master chief's story arc in the original
bungie trilogy would reach a
well-deserved climax in halo 3
aided by a nice graphical update with
its debut on the xbox 360.
the campaign expanded to allow up to
four player co-op missions but only two
players could play on each console at a
time
requiring either system link or xbox
live for that full party of four
halo 3 also introduced support weapons
these heavy weapons would take the
player out into a third person viewpoint
and
offer some pretty good firepower at the
expense of mobility
another evolution of its gameplay was
the use of equipment
although you could only use equipment
once each type would shift the gameplay
and allow the player to incorporate
various abilities some of those
abilities included the bubble shield the
trip mine
and the power drain and quickly became
staples in the halo franchise
halo 3 was the first time that players
got to experience forge
allowing players to adjust existing maps
to create an individualized gameplay
experience
one of the dlc maps foundry was one of
the first maps designed specifically
with forage in mind and
all of the maps and forage could be
saved and shared among the community
being on the xbox 360 infrastructure
multiplayer on xbox live experienced
several booms in terms of the user
interface and ease of access
players would group up in parties on the
360 and then hop into matches together
halo 3 took significant steps towards
integrating modes that weren't just
giving different ways to play but
different ways to experience the game
for example theater was a neat concept
that gave players the ability to
re-watch matches and record safe footage
both from campaign and multiplayer modes
and became a popular addition
halo 3 odst's gameplay shifts from the
original trilogy
you play as odsts or orbital dropshop
troopers meaning you no longer have the
ability to dual wield
the energy shield was also gone and in
its place was a mechanic that involved
stamina
creating a gameplay experience similar
to the first halo
odst also offered visual head changes in
its visor mode which would illuminate
enemies allies and items of interest in
all different colors
multiplayer in odst was just halo 3 and
shared halo 3's servers
the multiplayer came on a separate disk
that was practically halo 3 with the
addition of three odst maps citation
heretic and longshore the campaign would
still allow players to go through the
story cooperatively but the structure of
odst's campaign departed from the
typical linear storytelling of past halo
games
odst had a more open world campaign
allowing you to reach several
objectives or beacons in any given order
in the open world section taking place
in new mombasa
you play as a rookie odst but would also
play
as missing comrades during flashback
missions to piece together what happened
to them
this concept of storytelling allowed the
player to gradually unravel the plot at
their own pace
while allowing them to explore a new
mombasa odst
also introduced fire fight which was the
first horde mode in the halo franchise
it consisted of enemy waves growing more
difficult the longer you survived
and the mood also allowed for online
matchmaking system link
local play and split screen co-op
one of the most beloved games in the
franchise halo reach was a prequel to
the original bungie trilogy
the main character in reach was another
spartan super soldier
noble six which meant that the energy
shield was back
but so was the health bar requiring an
extra eye during combat sequences akin
to combat evolved
the rest of the noble team consisted of
a diverse cast of characters which
encouraged different play styles
throughout the campaign
due to the specific gameplay sequences
in one instance you
aggressively pursue an enemy with noble
5 weapons free
another mission would have you posted up
on a sniper outpost with noble 3
requiring more deliberate shots and
movement to make your way past a larger
covenant group
equipment in reach now had a cool down
timer preventing any spamming and moved
away from the single use concept in halo
3.
jetpacks sprint and active camo were
just some of the game's different
equipment allowing for different
gameplay styles and interactions during
combat
for the first time in halo there was an
aerial dogfighting mission
and in this chapter the player flies a
unsc ship and defends the objective by
defeating waves of covenant ships the
gameplay lets you fly from a third
person perspective
gave you several ways to maneuver in
space and was an unexpected change of
pace
fire fight and forage returned in reach
along with multiplayer and reach
exclusive game types such as headhunter
generator defense and invasion with many
of them incorporating new ideas like
pitting spartan humans against covenant
elites
at last we've reached the era where
bungie officially departed
despite some reservations from the
community halo 4 incorporated several
exciting additions to the halo universe
and the gameplay first off was the
introduction of completely new enemy
faction
the prometheans these enemies had
different types of knights or crawlers
and brought a whole new set of weapons
unsc and covenant weapons also returned
offering a varied arsenal for master
chief
new armor abilities consisted of things
like a hard light shield promethium
vision
and an auto sentry turret halo 4 also
allowed the player to sprint at any time
until this point halo had always kept
the player at one set speed
which was growing increasingly at odds
with other modern shooters that had
embraced sprinting as a core gameplay
mechanic
new story additions were added
post-release in the form of spartan ops
the episodic mode was playable
cooperatively
or solo and replaced firefight mode
altogether
unfortunately some of the most
significant changes from the past halo
games
weren't necessarily welcome in halo 4.
the multiplayer was overhauled much to
the dismay of the online community
the competitive multiplayer was known as
war games and
gone were the weapons placed around the
map in favor of call of duty style
loadouts and ordinance drops
players could now spawn in automatically
with whatever standard weapons they saw
fit to use
meanwhile ordinance drops would
gradually appear as a match progress
visible to the player and contain the
more powerful weapons
halo 5 guardians introduced several
changes that brought halo in line with
aspects typical of first-person shooters
that were oddly absent from halo games
in the past abs was now available for
every gun
and armored abilities were replaced with
spartan abilities which involved using
thrusters to move in any direction
you could use the thrusters in different
ways for example you could quickly
perform a side dash and gain leverage
against an enemy
meanwhile using that same thruster while
sprinting at full speed would trigger a
shoulder bash
and even crouching while in a full
sprint would perform a slide
the first we'd seen in the series in
halo 5 you could command and give out
instructions to your ai squad
and unlike in previous games they would
stick around for the entire game
if playing with friends in co-op the
squad mates would take the role of the
ai squad
which meant different gameplay
experiences since each character had
different starting weapons
and even visual head changes similar to
halo 2's arbiter
spartan lock was a playable character
opposite of master chief
despite the co-op's support halo 5 only
allowed players to join together through
xbox live
with split screen becoming a thing of
the past the lack of local play extended
to halo 5's multiplayer as well
however halo 5 made several changes to
improve upon the missteps of halo 4.
the arena-style combat was back with the
removal of weapon loadouts
if you wanted a dmr or a battle rifle
you could no longer spawn in with it but
had to scour the map to find it in its
spawn point
war zone was a brand new multiplayer
mode that makes ai enemies
alongside an opposing human team the
massive 24 player mode had teams compete
by clearing out ai enemies and bases to
earn victory points
defeating ai bosses enemies and
maintaining control of the bases would
gain victory points
however there was an additional way to
win the match if a team captured all
three bases they could attack and
destroy an enemy power core
a new rec system could be used in the
mode encouraging players to commit to
the multiplayer and redeem their wreck
points in war zones
confirmed halo 5 also looked fantastic
visually thanks to the xbox one's
processing power
but now that we near the final quarter
of 2020 all eyes are ahead to the new
console generation
343 industry undoubtedly has to find a
way to bring master chief back to the
forefront of badassery while maintaining
halo's multiplayer legacy
we need to run no
we need to fight which brings us to one
of the most anticipated games of the
decade
so far
halo infinite has finally revealed its
gameplay and right out of the gate we
can already spot several changes
the grapple shot was shown off plenty
during the xbox game showcase demo
and it allowed master chief to grab
items from a distance and throw them at
enemies
or lock onto objects and enemies
themselves to close the gap rapidly
another piece of equipment spotted in
the demo was called a drop wall and it
mimicked the bubble shield but spanned a
wider
area taking up damage directed at master
chief
another subtle action confirmed was the
return of the sprint and the slide
but there were also a bunch of weapons
shown off like automatic machine guns
and
a new shotgun the primary antagonist
this time around
is the banished a splinter group of
covenant that features many of halo's
classic
enemies and the return of the brutes
there's a tactical map in the demo as
well that implies a larger open world
and elements of a non-linear pace halo
has come
a long way since the early days of
combat evolved
let us know in the comments if the demo
has you sold on halo infinite or if
you're excited to see more as we get
closer to launch
with all the hype surrounding halo
infinite there's sure to be even more
content to look forward to
so for any news impressions and video
content on halo
infinite stick to gamespot
you